[Music]
the University of Alberta has a lot
going for it it's pretty it's bear
collection is on point and it's home to
many and eccentric and clever inventor
are you human like this fella Cory
Matthews is an AI researcher who comes
with a sidekick
[Music]
tell me about this guy a little bit oh
yeah sure
so this is blueberry on blueberry I've
deployed the improv system so there's an
artificial improv system running on
blueberry right now yes that's right
Quarry does improv comedy with the robot
I've been doing improv longer than I've
been doing computing science I've been
doing it for 12 years and I thought you
know there's no more natural convergence
than taking some of these
state-of-the-art systems and putting
them up onstage
things like a ventriloquist or this is
like a new-age strange twist on it the
piece that's different is that I don't
know what it will say anything that
comes from the system is generating
live-in-the-moment
very I I created you I downloaded a
voice into your brain so that you could
perform in front of these people I don't
know what you're gonna say either to
give blueberry the power of surreal
Canadian improv Corrie first had to
create an AI that could bring the funny
step one he feeds blueberry the dialogue
from a bunch of movies 100 2000 movies
to be exact
all the movies every movie for a hundred
years and that's just so I can learn
language see how somebody responds to
somebody else that's exactly right yeah
it builds kind of a language model step
two he trains blueberry just like you
train a dog rewarding it when it makes
sense and punishing it when it spits out
gibberish time to put this wannabe kid
in the hall to the test yeah start
improvising okay campers we're gonna get
ready for a real baseball game grab your
gloves and grab your baseball bats and
let's get out there especially you
Franklin okay okay well why aren't you
ready for the match okay come on
Franklin you know how I feel about you
but you got to keep your head in the
game right now oh Jesus put down the bat
Franklin what are you doing hi I've got
nothing to hide
look this is all I am okay obviously
some of the responses are a little bit
weird but then it's really funny because
then as you're going along it did hit a
couple things perfectly and then it's
like yeah I mean it's extra hilarious
because oh yeah that's going
blueberry may not be ready for its
second city audition just yet but Cory
has a higher purpose making AI relatable
there is fear in society of AI so we are
kind of humanizing this AI we're taking
it down a peg we're saying don't be
afraid of this tech look at how cute it
is look at how kind of naive it is
[Music]
there's no flipside to that though then
you make it cute and and then people
start to accept it and you know then
then we wake up I don't think that will
happen in my time I'm sorry you had to
hear that blueberry when you're ready to
turn Corey into a human puppet give me a
ring and we'll bring the cameras thanks
for watching and if you want to see more
hello world click on the link to
subscribe